y
resulta aprobado con 38 con 38 votos
afirmativos y 29 negativos y una
abstención resulta aprobado se convierte
en ley y se gira al poder ejecutivo
argentina a su historia y se convierte
en el país más grande de américa latina
en consagrar el derecho al aborto tras
un maratónico debate de más de 12 horas
el senado dio luz verde a la ley de
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo
hasta la semana 14 con un margen de
votos menos estrecho de lo esperado los
colectivos feministas estallaron en
júbilo con la decisión tenemos
información desde buenos aires
los líderes de la unión europea firmaron
los tratados que definirán las
relaciones con reino unido otras
empresas y que se produce a la
medianoche de este jueves ahora el pacto
a la sede del gobierno británico para
ser ratificado estará en vigor
provisionalmente hasta el 28 de febrero
cuando debe ser confirmado formalmente
por ambas partes tenemos información
desde londres
la contagiosa variante del coronavirus
detectada en reinounido llegó a chile y
con ello américa latina' las autoridades
sanitarias indicaron que las contagiadas
una chilena que estuvo en territorio
británico e ingresó al país el pasado 22
de diciembre la nueva variante también
fue identificada en colorado eeuu donde
el presidente electo joe biden advierte
que los esfuerzos de vacunación no
avanzan lo suficientemente rápido
buen día para todos bienvenidos a esta
emisión de noticias en france 24 soy
valentina torres sánchez este es un día
histórico para argentina y para los
derechos de la mujer con 38 votos a
favor 29 en contra y una abstención el
senado argentino aprobó la ley de
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo que
permite el acceso a esta práctica hasta
la semana 14 de gestación y más allá en
los casos previamente permitidos es
decir por violación o riesgo para la
vida de la madre
la normativa fue impulsada por el
presidente alberto fernández que aseguró
vía twitter que ahora argentina es una
sociedad mejor miles de personas a favor
y en contra se congregaron alrededor de
la sede legislativa para darnos más
detalles al respecto conectamos con
nuestro corresponsal natalio cosoi
natalio buenos días una decisión
histórica que convierte a argentina en
el país más grande de américa latina en
aprobar el aborto que reacciones se han
producido hasta el momento
bueno ha habido reacciones primero por
supuesto en las calles de estas mujeres
que hace años están reclamando este
cambio en la ley yo conversé de apenas
se conoció el resultado de eso de las 4
de la mañana ahora de buenos aires con
algunas personas que conozco de la
campaña o mujeres que se están
vinculadas también con este pedido de
cambio de la ley están muy emocionadas
muy contentas hablaban de que con esto
se termina el aborto clandestino en
argentina también desde el oficialismo
hubo reacciones celebratorias el
presidente alberto fernández quien dijo
que era un compromiso de campaña de el
que saliera esta ley y por lo tanto
sentía que estaba cumpliendo con esta
promesa también desde el oficialismo
quienes acompañaron esta ley por
supuesto los opositores a la ley quienes
están en contra no están nada conformes
incluso hablaron de la posibilidad de
llevar esta normativa a la justicia para
tratar de revertirlo o tratar de
combatirla en los tribunales pero por el
lado de los verdes de quienes estaban a
favor de esta transformación de este
cambio en argentina que mantiene al
aborto como algo penalizado desde mil
921 casi 100 años este
radical e histórico para estas mujeres y
para estas personas que pedían esta
transformación en el país natal yo en
principio se hablaba de una votación muy
ajustada pero el resultado fue más
holgado de lo esperado
así es el poroteo que es la palabra que
se usa aquí para el conteo de los votos
antes de que se dé la sesión daba
incluso en algunos momentos un empate
pero hubo algunos algunos elementos
clave sobre todo el hecho de que hubo un
acuerdo al inicio de la sesión de que el
poder ejecutivo hacer una modificación
cuando promulga esta ley un cambio de
una palabra no va a hablar de salud
integral sino de salud en los casos en
que se sigue permitiendo el aborto más
allá de las 14 semanas de gestación que
es algo similar a lo que ya existe no es
el aborto voluntario sino que es el
legal en casos específicos como
violación o de salud y riesgo para la
vida de la madre no será más salud
integral como estaba en el proyecto
original sino que el poder ejecutivo lo
cambiara a salud y eso permitió que
algunos senadores que estaban indecisos
cambiaran su voto de hecho fue muy
contundente el cambio 38 votos fue lo
que tuvo en 2018 el senado el rechazo de
una ley similar así que podemos decir
que claramente el senado se dio vuelta
en esta en esta nueva legislatura y
cambió radicalmente su voto porque la
diferencia es muy
importante nueve votos de diferencia no
es menor en un en un senado que tiene
setenta y algo de banca digo setenta y
algo porque hubo ausentes en esta
ocasión algo que también jugó a favor de
la aprobación de esta iniciativa
legislativa natalio muchas gracias por
toda esta información estaremos muy
pendientes de las movilizaciones que se
esperan en las próximas horas cambiamos
de tema porque los presidentes de la
comisión y del consejo europeo úrsula
von der leyen y charles michel firmaron
los tres tratados que regularán las
relaciones entre el reino unido y la
unión europea a partir del viernes los
acuerdos ratificados por el bloque
tratan sobre comercio y cooperación
intercambio de información clasificada y
uso de energía atómica ahora tendrán que
ser aprobados por el parlamento
británico y luego firmados por el primer
ministro boris johnson nuestra
corresponsal en londres louis ha pulido
conectamos con ella a esta hora para que
nos den más detalles al respecto
luisa que se espera el reino unido- tras
la firma de estos tratados en la unión
europea
un avión de la fuerza aérea real
británica traerá de bruselas a londres
el acuerdo para que pueda ser firmado
por el primer ministro boris johnson
inicia entonces pasado mañana una nueva
relación entre estos dos aliados
estratégicos entretanto el parlamento
británico debate a esta hora la ley de
la futura relación entre la unión
europea y el reino unido- será un debate
sencillo largo pero que se prevé que
será calmado porque el gobierno tiene
las mayorías y la oposición ha dicho que
lo apoyará a será una jornada larga
porque el trámite legislativo que
inicialmente se hace en semana se tendrá
que hacer solo hoy la cámara de los
comunes y la cámara de los lores
entonces lo aprobarán se prevé que esta
noche la reina isabel dará su firma y
dará su consentimiento y entonces el
reino unido y la unión europea iniciarán
un nuevo capítulo
luisa muchas gracias por todos estos
datos estamos pendientes de lo que
ocurra en las próximas horas continuamos
en reinounido porque el ente regulador
de medicamentos de este país aprobó el
uso de la vacuna de sarro
por la universidad de oxford y el
laboratorio astrazéneca se trata de la
segunda vacuna autorizada en reino unido
tras la de facer y bayonne tec y el país
ya tiene 100 millones de dosis
aseguradas que servirán para inmunizar a
50 millones de personas el fármaco de
astrazéneca puede almacenarse en neveras
normales no requiere de los 70 grados
bajo cero que si son necesarios para el
de facer bayón tec
y la nueva variante de coronavirus
detectada por primera vez en reino unido
sigue propagándose por el mundo eeuu
detectó este martes su primer caso de
dicha mutación y chile se convirtió en
el primero de suramérica en registrar un
caso el informe es de rodrigo sedano
la nueva variante del cobi 19 sigue
propagándose por el mundo y por el
continente americano en chile las
autoridades sanitarias confirmaron el
positivo de una mujer chilena que
regresó al país el 22 de diciembre
procedente del reino unido aunque se
encuentra en buen estado de salud fue
trasladada a un hospital de forma
preventiva y tras la detección de este
caso las autoridades dictaminaron
medidas extraordinarias hemos decidido
que tomar una medida absolutamente
transitoria que a partir del día 31 de
diciembre todos los chilenos todos los
extranjeros residentes en chile y todos
los extranjeros que ingresen a nuestro
país deben mantener una cuarentena de 10
días también eeuu registró el primer
caso el gobernador de colorado
jared polis anunció que un hombre de 20
años ya se encuentra en aislamiento
preocupa que el joven no había viajado
recientemente
hoy hemos descubierto el primer caso en
colorado de la variante de 117 de 19 la
misma variante descubierta en el reino
unido- la salud y la seguridad de los
habitantes de colorado es nuestra máxima
prioridad y monitorearemos este caso así
como todos los indicadores de kobe 19
muy de cerca más de 20 naciones han
registrado en sus territorios esta nueva
variante del virus que se dice es hasta
un 70% más infeccioso y aunque han
surgido interrogantes sobre si esta
variante mutar a hasta un punto que
pueda resistirse a las vacunas las
farmacéuticas mostraron confianza en que
sus antídotos seguirán siendo eficaces
para finalizar vamos a dar un vistazo a
nuestra página web france24 puntocom que
a esta hora titula argentina legaliza la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo en
todas las causales
a ustedes gracias por acompañarnos
volvemos en breve con más noticias aquí
en france 24
[Música]